okay we are about to start week two of  our course week two is very rich in  content quite a lot of material for you  to see in your videos take your time  that's the beauty of these courses you  do it according to your own drummer so  to speak but we we think we've got some  very exciting and important work for you  ahead what you're going to do is going  to be using interactive tools online  you're going to look at aperture you're  going to look at point of view you're  going to look exposure you're going to  look at iso all those highly technical  issues that you have to know i'm going  to continue to say to you read your  manual there's no way I could teach you  every camera there is around but now we  get to the nitty-gritty of the course  and you're going to have a blast I  promise have fun